zdf heute live ganz herzlich willkommen
heute geht es bei uns in die berge die
könne man zwar wohl nicht versetzen aber
trotzdem einige wichtige entscheidungen
und weichenstellungen sollen getroffen
werden so hat es olaf scholz gesagt das
ganze bezieht sich natürlich auf den g 7
gipfel also das treffen der sieben
größten demokratischen
wirtschaftsmächte und zurück schloss
elmau so heißt der tagungsort in den
bayerischen alpen in den kommenden drei
tagen in den fokus der weltpolitik und
wir sind live für euch mit dabei und wir
haben bereits heute einiges vor mehrere
schalten zu korrespondenten zu
aktivisten aber auch zu experten vor ort
also lohnt sich dran zu bleiben und uns
dann natürlich auch wie immer eure
fragen und kommentare zuzuschicken per e
mail oder über unsere social media
kanäle und wir schauen mal gemeinsam auf
einige bilder des ersten gipfeltages da
sehen wir unter anderem das
traditionelle familien foto mitsamt den
staats und regierungschefs der sieben
teilnehmenden länder plus der beiden eu
spitzen funktionäre die auch dabei sind
und danach ging es dann auch relativ
zügig zu einer ersten arbeitssitzung
ins schloss tja und auch darüber
sprechen wir jetzt mit unserem
korrespondenten vor ort da steht der
thomas reichert der für uns eben genau
da ist genauer gesagt im schönen
garmisch partenkirchen zu diesem
landkreis nämlich gehört der am
tagungsort das kommt uns gerade auch
noch mal genauer anschauen schloss elmau
wie gesagt liegt auf etwa 1000 meter
höhe ein paar kilometer von garmisch
entfernt also thomas die kulisse stimmte
imposantes panorama rund um den gipfel
ja was glaubst du wie imposant werden
die entscheidungen auf dem gipfel die
ist eine einschätzung
also das kann man noch etwas schwer
sagen wie imposant die entscheidungen
werden ob sie wirklich mit dieser in der
tat imposanten kulisse mithalten können
wir sind in gewisser weise in hörweite
zu erinnern die hubschrauber die sie
vielleicht im hintergrund hören das sind
die shuttles die medienvertreter oder
anderes personal zum schluss ein aus
fliegen also insofern auch hier in
garmisch partenkirchen ist elmau sind
die g7 sehr präsent sehr hörbar präsent
ob es wirklich so zu sagen ähnlich
imposanter beschlüsse geben wird wie
gesagt das ist offen bundeskanzler
scholz hat am samstag und die latte da
ein bisschen niedrig gelegt hat gesagt
auch wenn der gibt lebende werkstatt
findet er wird vermutlich keine berge
versetzen denn die g7 sind letztlich ein
ehrloser flucht anders als jetzt keine
riesigen institution hinter sich sondern
sie sind nun eine vereinigung quasi der
selbstvergewisserung des westens diese
selbstvergewisserung ist natürlich im
moment mit russlands angriffskrieg auf
die ukraine besonders wichtig worum es
hier also gehen wird ist die ukraine und
sind vor allem drei punkte um die es den
g7 wirklich besonders geht das sind
einerseits die waffenlieferungen
andererseits die sanktionen und drittens
die frage wie man die wirtschaftlichen
folgen dieses krieges in den eigenen
ländern abfedern kann zu den letzten
beiden punkten hat der us-präsident
gleich mal vorgelegt hat bei sanktionen
gesagt man müsste eine preisobergrenze
für öllieferungen
einführen um zu verhindern dass putin
trotz sanktionen lässt sich noch mehr
einnimmt durch höher als noch vor dem
krieg und zweitens bei den wirtschaft
bei den wirtschafts hilfen hatte er
vorgeschlagen
das auch
entschuldigung bei den sanktionen hatte
weiter vorgeschlagen dass gold
lieferungen abgesetzt werden das also
kein gold mehr geliefert werden soll
insgesamt das wichtigste für die g7 ist
wirklich eine ein signal der
geschlossenheit dass man also zeigt auch
wenn dieser krieg russlands gegen die
ukraine wahrscheinlich noch monate
dauern wird und auch die eigenen
gesellschaften unter erheblichen stress
setzen wird die g7 halten zusammen und
gehen in die gleiche richtung das ist
das signal das von hier aus gehen soll
und dass möglicherweise dann am ende
vielleicht sogar berge versetzen wird
man wird sehen ok der bundeskanzler hat
sich auch heute schon in einem ersten
kurzen statement zu wort gemeldet am
frühen nachmittag wir hören da auch noch
mal kurz rein sprechen dann gleich
weiter
die erste arbeitssitzung ging daneben
auch umweltwirtschaft alle g 7 staaten
sind besorgt über die krisen die wir
gegenwärtig zu bewältigen haben
in einigen ländern sinkende
wachstumsraten steigende inflation
rohstoffknappheit und störungen der
lieferkette
das sind alles keine kleinen
herausforderungen vor denen wir stehen
und deshalb müssen wir auch gemeinsam
verantwortung tragen
also man will verantwortung übernehmen
vielleicht skizzieren wir gerade noch
mal das programm jetzt der nächsten tage
also heute sind die g7 thomas unter sich
morgen werden dann auch gast nationen
aus dem globalen süden erwartet was ist
das für ein signal was erhofft man sich
davon
also vielleicht auch mal ganz kurz zu
heute es ging um die wirtschaftlichen
folgen für die eigenen länder wir
sprachen schon darüber heute abend soll
es dann im ganz kleinen kreis um die
frage von weiteren waffenlieferungen
gehen auch da wollen sie sich hier
abstimmen aufschluss über und morgen in
der tat christopher sind die fünf
gastländer da das ist ein signal des
bundeskanzlers scholz ganz bewusst aus
sendet an den sogenannten globalen süden
der teil sein soll dieses g7 clubs oder
jedenfalls darin eingebunden werden soll
gekommen sind
und werden morgen gast sein indien
indonesien senegal südafrika und
argentinien
das sind alles länder für die der
russlands angriffskrieg in der ukraine
weit weg ist die sich dazu entweder
neutral oder eher skeptisch verhalten
dass sanktionen und waffenlieferungen
für die ukraine und sanktionen gegen
russland angeht man hat das bei der
un-vollversammlung gesehen als studiert
abgestimmt wurde
seine galt und indien haben da zum
beispiel sich enthalten was sanktionen
und die verurteilung russlands angeht es
ist dies diese teilnahme dieser fünf
gastländer muss man vermutlich sehen in
dem zusammenhang in der perspektive
eines geostrategischen versuchs diese
länder in das westliche lager
rüberzuziehen es gab am donnerstag einen
sogenannten brics gipfel also der länder
brasilien russland indien
china und südafrika wo umgekehrt
russland und china versucht haben diese
länder den globalen süden auf ihre seite
zu ziehen was sich hier abzeichnet ist
sozusagen eine bipolare ordnung von
meinerseits freiheitlichen demokratien
andererseits autoritären regime die
russland und poster und china und in
diesem jahr sozusagen kampf um die
vorherrschaft versucht man eben länder
wie diese fünf gastland auf die eigene
seite zu ziehen das ist morgen das große
thema und der große versuch zu zeigen
ihr seid uns wichtig und deswegen wollen
wir mit euch in ruhe sprechen
im verlauf des streams heute noch mal
eingehen und vielleicht etwas nochmal
zum abschluss kurz die frage auch an
dich wie nimmst du insgesamt die
atmosphäre das drumherum bei diesem
gipfel war sie seine heimliche aufwand
der betrieben werden muss
riesiger aufwand und es erinnert
sozusagen im inneren kreis und trotzdem
so ein bisschen an einem klassentreffen
wo unterschiedliche rollen vergeben sind
stolz ist ganz ersichtlich der etwas
aufgeregte gastgeber der versucht alle
leute dabei sammeln zu halten und selbst
natürlich auch eine gute figur zu machen
wo boris johnson der britische premier
auftaucht da wird es in bernau hat in
einer runde heute bei der ersten
arbeitssitzung hat gleich gesagt
angesichts der sommerlichen temperaturen
hier sollen wir jetzt alle die jackett
ausziehen oder müssen wir putin zeigen
dass er das wir härter sind als er
foto wiederum ist derjenige der dann
immer aufpasst dass sozusagen bei den
allen offenen mikro sie es hier gibt die
staats und regierungschefs dann nichts
unvorsichtiges sagen er ist ein
gebranntes kind weil er beim nato gipfel
in london 2009 10 zu sehr über trump
gelästert hat und dass viel auf also der
hat heute gerade mal schnell nach rom
beiden und die eu kommissionspräsident
den von der neuen von den mikros
weggezogen insgesamt also wie ein
klassentreffen aber eben auch die
atmosphäre wo man in ruhe und sozusagen
ohne formalistische protokoll über dinge
mal im grunde reden kann das hat heute
eben auch noch mal auf seine
pressekonferenz deutlich gemacht das ist
der eigentliche sinn des g7 trotz dieses
riesigen aufwands der drum herum
passiert vielen dank thomas reichert für
diese ersten eindrücke aus garmisch
partenkirchen bei schloss elmau und wir
gucken natürlich auch immer ein bisschen
auf die bilder die sich uns zeigen von
dort sollte sich der bundeskanzler noch
mal äußern dann würden wir dann auch
versuchen dann noch mal ein statement
nachzureichen machen jetzt aber im
moment weiter mit dem g7-gipfel der ja
nicht nur befürworter hat im gegenteil
es gibt auch ganz entschiedenen protest
gegen die veranstaltung und gegen das
format auch als solches und wir schalten
jetzt nochmal nach garmisch zu meiner
kollegin alicia jung hallo alissa was
lässt sich denn bislang zu dem protest
sagen du stehst offenbar genau
mittendrin
ich stehe in der innenstadt von garmisch
partenkirchen und während man auf
schloss elmau ganz in ruhe tag ist hier
gerade der protestmarsch durch die
innenstadt zu ende gegangen und hier
findet die schlusskundgebung statt ihr
könnt das hinter mir sehen also gerade
hier befinden sich eben noch ganz ganz
viele menschen die hiergegen dem g7
gipfel protestieren das ist nicht nur
heute in garmisch partenkirchen so das
war auch schon gestern in münchen der
fall dort waren 20.000 menschen erwartet
am ende des tages waren es aber wohl nur
rund 5000 menschen und auch heute hier
sind wohl weniger teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer gekommen als erwartet
nichtsdestotrotz sie gehen hier auf die
straße für klimagerechtigkeit gegen
kapitalismus gegen militarismus und
versuchen hier auf sich aufmerksam zu
machen und versuchen hier laut zu sein
und mobil zu machen denn man muss dazu
sagen das ganze findet hier ja eine
ganze ecke ein ganzes stück entfernt von
schloss elmau stadt also jener
innenstadt von garmisch partenkirchen
die regierungs und staatschefs in ellmau
die sind ja abgesperrt findet dieser
gipfel statt und die sind da also ganz
unter sich und der protest der bus hier
stattfinden das finden auch nicht alle
so gut sie würden natürlich viel lieber
ganz in der nähe des schlosses
demonstrieren aber gut so ist es nunmal
es ist jetzt also hier weiter entfernt
der ganze protest und des dann war es
auch schon so dass also dort haben
verschiedene bündnisse aufgerufen
greenpeace wwf und die haben natürlich
auch zu spüren bekommen ein bisschen
weiter entfernt sind von dem geschehen
wo also die wichtigen und staatsmänner
zusammensitzen ich habe jetzt hier bei
mir dieser göldner von greenpeace die
war nämlich gestern beim protest dabei
und hat mehrere protestaktionen mit
greenpeace durchgeführt hallo dieser
göldner
wieso habt ihr sorge dass ihr vielleicht
dadurch dass er natürlich nicht so nah
ran dürft also nicht nach schloss elmau
dürft dass ihr da überhaupt genug gehör
findet ich denke die herausforderung ist
jetzt mit sehr vielfältigen protest von
wir uns gehört zu schaffen was das
gerade gesagt wir waren gestern
gemeinsam in münchen auf der straße
jetzt hier in garmisch partenkirchen
findet eine demonstration statt und auch
greenpeace war schon rund um diesen ort
in garmisch partenkirchen aktiv wir
haben gestern nacht am 10 die aktivistin
ein sogenanntes werk vorjahr entzündet
das ist ja so eine tradition im
alpenraum dass man so um die
sommersonnenwende also genau jetzt feuer
entzündet auf den berggipfel und unsere
aktivisten sind auf den wachsenden stein
geklettert und haben dort einen berg
voller in form eines zeichens entzündet
und das ist auch unsere botschaft in der
aufforderung an die g7 wir haben ein
zeichen des friedens gesetzt und für uns
ist klar wer frieden will muss raus aus
den fossilen energien und ja heute
vormittag sind dann eine gruppe von
aktiven von der greenpeace jugend also
die jüngere generation auf die zugspitze
gestiegen und haben auch dort noch mal
diese botschaft auf den höchsten gipfel
getragen und ja klar ich meine die
staats und regierungschefs treffen sich
dort völlig abgeschottet von der
außenwelt und ich denke gerade deswegen
ist dieser protest auch so so richtig
und jetzt ist es natürlich so dass auch
ein bisschen ich hab's angesprochen
weniger teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
als erwartet unterwegs waren was sind
die gründe dafür liegt es daran dass
einfach vielleicht auch die sorge war
dass man nicht richtig durchdringen kann
mit dem thema klimagerechtigkeit wenn
sich jetzt natürlich auch vieles um die
auswirkungen des ukraine krieges steht
oder was glaubst du warum waren
eigentlich so viel weniger menschen als
erwartet jetzt bei der demonstration
gestern und auch heute ich glaube es
sind wirklich gerade schwierige zeiten
für mobilisierung und menschen auf die
straße zu bringen der krieg hat uns in
atem
wir erleben dass wenn wir alles teurer
wird es ist immer noch corona pandemie
aber ich alles gesagt glaube dass es
auch daran liegt dass die leute nicht
mehr wirklich vertrauen oder der glauben
dass diese gipfeltreffen überhaupt
erfolge bringen wir haben das schon so
oft erlebt ist der staats und
regierungschefinnen zu weltklimagipfel
treffen zu g7 zu g20 gipfeln und die
ergebnisse einfach nie ausreichen also
ich kann auch irgendwie nachvollziehen
wenn leute sagen was bringt das
eigentlich wenn bei diesem gipfeltreffen
so widerlich rauskommt und ich denke das
muss ein klarer auftrag sein an die
staatschefs die sich jetzt hier treffen
auch dieses vertrauen wieder zu bilden
und zu zeigen neben gipfel kann auch was
vernünftiges bei rumkommen hast du
persönlich aber sorge dass es vielleicht
auch nichts bringen könnte hast du sorge
dass ihr nicht gehört werdet mich
gesehen werde ich denke wir werden hier
schon gehört mit unserem protest aktion
das sind ja wirklich mehrere die frage
ist natürlich reicht dieser druck aus
damit die staats und regierungschefs
mehr tun und um völlig ehrlich zu sein
mich macht das irgendwie ziemlich
pessimistisch ich meine es deutschland
die zu diesem gipfel eingeladen haben
deutschland hat den vorsitz der g 7 und
wir erleben gerade einen bundeskanzler
scholz der wirklich um die halbe welt
reist um neue erdgas die es zu schließen
erstellt milliardenschwere investitionen
neue erdgas infrastrukturen aussicht und
das in zeiten der klimakrise und ja ich
habe total sorge dass dieses thema
klimagerechtigkeit jetzt irgendwie und
vom tisch verrät dabei ist es eigentlich
gerade in diesen zeiten so wichtig über
klimaschutz zu sprechen dabei
klimaschutz und frieden schaffen gehört
zusammen also der krieg in der ukraine
und die klimakrise haben einfach eine
gemeinsamkeit und das sind die fossilen
energien es sind die einnahmen aus gas
auf öl aus kohle die putins krieg
finanzieren es sind die emissionen aus
gas aus kohle diese klimakrise anheizen
und diese klimakrise ist es eben auch
die inneren ressourcen wie wasser knapp
werden oder wie fruchtbares land das sie
dann weitere kriege und konflikte
befeuern und deswegen eben auch diese
botschaft wir müssen raus aus den
fossilen um eine gerechtere und
friedlichere welt zu schaffen
bundeskanzler scholz hat angekündigt die
g7 zu einem internationalen klima club
zum kern eines internationalen klima
clubs machen zu wollen glaubst du dass
es reicht dass das was bringt
also ich habe wirklich nicht das gefühl
dass wir gerade ein klima club brauchen
ich meine es gibt schon einen klima club
und das sind all die länder sämtliche
länder der welt die das pariser klima
abkommen unterzeichnet haben und gesagt
haben ja wir wollen die erhitzung bei
1,5 grad stoppen viel wichtiger als
jetzt irgendwie so ein club zu gründen
finde ich dass sich die g7 ja die
führenden industrienationen die
gemeinsam für ein drittel aller
treibhausgase verantwortlich sind die in
der atmosphäre gelandet sind seit der
industrialisierung und diese krise mit
verursacht das ziel sich zu ganz ganz
ganz konkreten zielen vor einem jahr
einigen um aus den fossilen auszusteigen
also dass sie wirklich nicht nur sagen
ja wir wollen und wir aus der kohle aus
stein sondern dass hier wirkt das
versprechen abgeben wir wollen bis 2030
aus der kohle aussteigen also dass sie
das mal wirklich konkret und verbindlich
festlegen und was die g7 machen müssen
zu hause ist das eine das wird aber
nicht ausreichend für 1,5 grad für klima
gerechtigkeit sondern es geht auch darum
andere länder der welt beim klimaschutz
bei der anpassung an die klimafolgen bei
der bewältigung klimabedingter schäden
und verluste zu unterstützen das heißt
sie gesehen werden dieser verantwortung
nicht gerecht und ein klima club
reicht's nicht weg nicht aus um diese
g7-gipfel für den klimaschutz zum erfolg
zu bringen
sagt lisa göldner von greenpeace und
damit christoph mich zurück zu dir nach
mainz und wir beobachten das ganze jetzt
noch weiter bei der demo was hier heute
in garmisch partenkirchen
jedenfalls die geräuschkulisse ist ein
und soll vielen dank alissa jung für das
gespräch mit dieser gelder und wir haben
es gerade schon gehört also das thema
klima und umweltschutz soll eine große
rolle spielen bei diesem gipfel wir alle
wissen die zeit drängt daran ändert auch
der krieg in der ukraine
bedauerlicherweise nichts und aus diesem
grund hat der bundeskanzler im vorfeld
einen anderen ansatz noch einmal in den
fokus gerückt klima club das stichwort
ist gerade auch schon gefallen wie man
da also vielleicht mehr schwung in die
sache bringen könnte und dazu jetzt mehr
wenn sich die welt auf den großen un
klimakonferenzen trifft dann geht es
dabei am ende immer um klimaschutzziele
auf dem kleinsten gemeinsamen nenner
olaf scholz will deshalb auf schloss
elmau einen kleineren klub mit größeren
klimazielen gründen einen sogenannten
klima club klingt exklusiv soll er aber
nicht sein diejenigen die in der
gleichen richtung unterwegs sind die
sollten sich zu verbünden zu einem
offenen klima club der für alle
zugänglich ist und der der delight
minded gewissermaßen den kampf gegen den
klimawandel auf nehmen angesichts der
tatsache dass das eine globale
herausforderung ist es das ja erst recht
richtig neben den g 7 soll der klima
club auch für andere staaten offen sein
die sich verpflichten bis 2050
klimaneutral zu wirtschaften mit
ähnlichen maßnahmen und einem
einheitlichen preis für den ausstoß von
co2 vor wettbewerbsnachteilen durch co2
intensive importe sollen sich die
clubmitglieder schützen durch einen
grenz ausgleich das problem co2 preise
gibt es noch nicht mal in allen g 7
staaten in den usa zum beispiel nur in
einzelnen bundesstaaten und stadt im
neuen klub schlange zu stehen könnten
andere länder mit vergeltungs zellen
drohen oder stress bei der
welthandelsorganisation machen
und wir sprechen mit christian decker
aus der umwelt redaktion des zdf auch er
ist vor ort wir sehen auch bei dir im
hintergrund die schönen berge also das
klingt so wir haben es gerade gehört was
den klima club angeht als sei diese idee
auch nicht so ganz einfach umzusetzen
ja diese idee des klima klubs die gibt
es schon seit vielen jahren muss man
sagen hintergrund ist dass das pariser
abkommen von 2015 eben keine konkreten
ziele definiert sondern es den ländern
auf der erde selbst überlässt maßnahmen
zu definieren ziele zu definieren um das
1,5 grad ziel zu erreichen und das hat
in der summe dazu geführt dass es unter
den ländern so eine art angst gibt dass
das land das am meisten voranschreitet
die
weitreichendsten klimaschutz maßnahmen
ergreift dass das im internationalen
wettbewerb wirtschaftlich einen nachteil
haben könnte also mein konkretes
beispiel wenn es in der eu einen co2
eine co2 abgabe auf die stahlproduktion
gibt die stahlproduzenten also geld
bezahlen müssen dann für die emissionen
dann und es gleichzeitig in china
stahlproduzenten gibt die den stahl
einfach so produzieren die können dann
könnte der chinesische stahl deutlich
billiger am ende seien als der eu stahl
und deshalb gibt es hier eine
möglicherweise eine wettbewerbs
ungleichheit und um das auszugleichen
gibt es die idee des klima clubs deshalb
ist die idee per se nicht schlecht aber
wir haben den beitrag gerade schon
gesehen es gibt natürlich im länder wie
die usa und möglicherweise auch japan
die bei einer solchen abgabe nicht
mitmachen werden und deshalb ist
fraglich was am ende bei diesen
g7-gipfel dabei rauskommen wird klar ist
aber dass gemeinsame standards für für
wirtschaftliche produktion was die
emissionen von treibhausgasen angeht das
dass dieser klima club in jedem fall
leisten könnte und das wäre ein
fortschritt das kann man in jedem fall
sagen er
fragt uns über youtube der g7 gipfel ist
schon alt also dass seine meinung dazu
wie wäre es mit mehr interessen
basierten gipfeln zum beispiel eben zum
thema klimaschutz also die frage die
dahinter steckt ist
g7 noch das richtige format
es gibt ja die un klimakonferenz die
jedes jahr stattfindet in der alle
staaten der welt sozusagen
zusammenkommen und über konkrete
maßnahmen diskutieren und auch
beschließen
trotzdem dass es so dass die g7
natürlich eine signalwirkung haben die
diese sieben staaten emittieren sehr
viele treibhausgase und sie sind
gleichzeitig sehr wirtschaft stark das
heißt der rest der welt erwartet von
diesen g7-staaten natürlich dass sie ein
stück weit voran gehen ohne
vorbildwirkung haben eine signalwirkung
haben deshalb ist dieses g7 forum hier
zwar keines wo verbindliche beschlüsse
gefasst werden dass aber trotzdem eine
wichtige rolle in diesem gefüge lauf der
welt hat kerstin schulz fragt uns über
facebook wen interessiert zur zeit der
klimaschutz wir haben doch im moment
ganz andere sorgen das stimmt natürlich
vordergründig aber der klimaschutz wird
uns alle in den nächsten jahren auch
noch beschäftigen das thema ist damit ja
leider nicht erledigt christian welche
rolle insgesamt würdest du sagen kann
deutschland als gastgeber spielen bei
diesem gipfel auch bei uns werden ja
schwierige diskussionen geführt derzeit
sei es entweder die rückkehr zur kohle
oder das zumindest mehr kohle genutzt
wird um sie zu verstromen um über den
gas mangel hinweg zu helfen selbst die
atomkraft ist wieder in der diskussion
manche würden sie gerne länger nutzen
kann die bundesrepublik trotzdem hier so
eine art grüner vorreiter sein
ja wie gesagt die signalwirkung diese g7
staaten die es in jedem fall groß und es
wird sicherlich auch sehr stark darauf
ankommen was es hier jetzt für
beschlüsse gibt zum ausstieg aus den
fossilen energien es gibt ja dieses
spannungsfeld zwischen einerseits der
energiesicherheit das heißt wir müssen
das gas das ist ja aus russland kamen
schnell ersetzen und das geht jetzt weil
die erneuerbaren energien einfach in den
letzten zehn 15 jahren viel zu langsam
ausgebaut wurden geht das jetzt erst mal
nur mit fossilen energien und
andererseits müssen wir im klimaschutz
vorankommen das heißt es wird ganz stark
darauf ankommen wie welche
vereinbarungen hier getroffen werden
welche ausstiegsszenarien auch getroffen
werden wenn wir jetzt hören dass neues
gas aus dem senegal zum beispiel kommen
soll dann hat das eben am ende
möglicherweise eine wirkung auf länder
wie china wie indien indonesien die nach
wie vor sehr stark auf kohle setzen und
die könnten sagen wenn die g7-staaten
auch weiterhin fossile energien benutzen
dann können wir das auch noch für eine
gewisse zeit das heißt es wird ganz
stark darauf ankommen ein signal zu
setzen dass die fossilen energien jetzt
erstmal nur als übergangslösung für 123
jahre für eine kürzere zeit und nicht
für die nächsten zehn zwanzig jahre als
energieträger genutzt werden ingolf
krise schreibt uns über facebook 180
millionen für pomp und selbstdarstellung
auf dem g7-gipfel ein wahnsinn das ist
natürlich eine riesensumme das stimmt
aber ich glaube man kann da auch
wiederum sagen das was du gerade
angesprochen hast christian es kommt
auch ein bisschen drauf an was am ende
dabei rauskommt wenn sich wirklich
substanzielles bewegen würde wäre das
geld vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht
angelegt neben dem thema klima wird auch
das welternährungstag eine bedeutende
rolle spielen auch da hat er kriegt
natürlich große auswirkungen sowohl auf
russland als auch auf die ukrainer
natürlich im besonderen maße worum
drehen sich da jetzt die diskussion in
den nächsten tagen
also das ernährungs thema ist sicherlich
ein ganz großes die neuesten zahlen
sagen dass 345 millionen menschen
weltweit im moment an hunger leiden und
es wird sicherlich darauf ankommen das
getreide aus der ukraine irgendwie raus
zu bekommen möglichst über den landweg
und es wird sicherlich auch um
finanzierungen gehen das un
programms für als den hunger bekämpfen
soll aber darüber hinaus wird es auch
schon um eine ganz grundsätzliche frage
gehen zu der die g7 staaten die
möglichkeit haben stellung zu nehmen
nämlich wie man mittelfristig den hunger
auf der welt stellt ob man in die eine
richtung geht und sagt wir fördern
intensive landwirtschaft mit
düngereinsatz mit pestizideinsatz oder
wir gehen einen anderen weg einen
nachhaltigeren weg und unterstützen zum
beispiel kleinbauern in afrika und
schaffen so die grundlage für eine
ökologische landwirtschaft der zukunft
das ist eine weichenstellung die im
prinzip hier auch bei g7 gestellt werden
könnte also viele spannende fragen die
da gestellt werden auch abseits des
großen themas krieg in der ukraine
vielen dank für diese einschätzung
christian decker war das aus der umwelt
redaktion des zdf dankeschön nach
garmisch partenkirchen
ja wir fast noch mal zusammen tag eins
des g 7 gipfel also auf schloss elmau
ein gipfel auf dem hohe erwartungen
ruhen angesichts der großen probleme der
wir uns oder denen wir uns
gegenübersehen im moment wir schauen
noch mal drauf was bislang heute
passiert ist mehr dazu von meinem
kollegen daniel thompson
er sei schon lange nicht mehr ski
gefahren erzählt us-präsident beiden dem
gastgeber mit blick auf die berge jede
smalltalk den vielen ernsten themen wie
ich zum mittagessen die erste
arbeitssitzung zur weltwirtschaftlichen
fragen energieversorgung etwa und
infektionen deshalb bin ich sehr froh
dass wir hier so viel zeit haben
miteinander zu sprechen ganz entfernt
von den typischen formalisierten
abläufen und auch so dass jeder das sagt
was ihm wirklich auf dem herzen liegt
das hat schon gleich bei der ersten
sitzung so geklappt impulse erhofft man
sich auch gegen die eskalierende
ernährungskrise russland sei dafür
allein verantwortlich spieler ein
gefährliches hunger spiel so der eu
ratspräsident und
helfen durch angriffe auf kritische
infrastrukturen dadurch dass
weizenfelder in schlachtfelder
verwandelt werden müssen familien und
kinder hunger leiden
gemeinsame investitionen und
infrastrukturprojekte waren am
nachmittag thema der zweite
arbeitssitzung in einer dritten geht es
ab 18 uhr um außen und
sicherheitspolitik
und wir sprechen jetzt mit sarah packung
von der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik sie hat den
schwerpunkt auf russlands außen und
sicherheitspolitik guten tag frau parker
hallo guten nachmittag mit welchen
erwartungen glauben sie mit welchen
überlegungen vielleicht auch dürfte
dieser gipfel eigentlich in moskau
verfolgt werden
also auch in moskau verfolgt man das
natürlich ganz genau und man schaut sich
vor allen dingen drei punkte an das ist
zum einen was beschließen die g 7
konkret und bezug auf russlands krieg in
der ukraine also beispielsweise neue
sanktionen dann ist es zum anderen wie
genau oder wie gut schafft es die g7
sich mit den partnerländern die hier
eingeladen sind wie beispielsweise
indien oder südafrika zu koordinieren
dann deren unterstützung natürlich in
der globalen politik gegen russland und
gegen russlands krieg in der ukraine ist
ganz zentral auch für die nachhaltigkeit
für die wirksamkeit der sanktionen und
das dritte ist sicherlich wie gut
schafft es die g7 sich trotz der
dominierenden krise in der ukraine und
des krieges in der ukraine eigentlich
auch auf andere fragen zu konzentrieren
also beispielsweise die steigenden
lebensmittelpreise und moskau hofft
natürlich dass es in allen drei
bereichen kaum fortschritte gibt auf das
kriegsgeschehen würde ich gerne noch
einmal zu sprechen kommen denn da ist
leider klar dass dieses nicht ruht jetzt
während des gipfels im gegenteil der
russische beschuss aus kiew der wurde
noch einmal intensiviert und dann
schauen wir noch mal drauf mit laura
rosinus
wieder trifft es unschuldige tiere
früher sonntagmorgen russische raketen
treffen ein wohnhaus mitten in der stadt
eine 7 jährige konnte aus den trümmern
gerettet werden ich hörte ein pfeifen
wachte auf und es gab einen sehr starken
schlag wurde weggestoßen das haus war
zerstört
mindestens fünf menschen wurden verletzt
eine person starb drei stockwerke
zerstört auch in das gebäude eines
kindergartens schlagen raketen ein drei
wochen lang war kiel verschont geblieben
heute wurde das ziel von 14 russischen
raketen
vielleicht ist es eine symbolische
aggression in diesen tagen es ist ein
symbolischer angriff
der ukrainische aussenminister kleber
fordert anschließend auf twitter der g 7
gipfel sollte mit mehr sanktionen gegen
russland und mehr schweren waffen für
die ukraine antworten denn während g7
auf schloss elmau takt kommt der krieg
wieder mehr in richtung westen
ja das klingt beunruhigend der krieg
kommt richtung westen vielleicht noch
einen kommentar zuvor von habe youtube
hoffentlich kommt genug substanzielles
dabei raus auch wenn es nicht so groß
kommuniziert wird in bezug auf den
gipfel die waffenlieferungen sind
wirklich wichtig so die meinung hier
also werden es gerade gesagt der krieg
kommt richtung westen wenn wir jetzt
wieder die westliche perspektive frau
tagung einnehmen worin dürfte dann das
hauptziel der sieben gipfel teilnehmer
für die nächsten tage bestehen
also die ziele dagegen sieben staaten
sind natürlich genau spiegelbildlich zu
dem was russland hofft was nicht
passiert besonderer fokus liegt
sicherlich auf zwei aspekte dass es eben
die koordinierung mit den partnerländern
denn deren unterstützung oder zumindest
nicht deren gegenwehr ist ganz
essenziell für den anstehenden g20
gipfel im juni sehen im herbst denn nur
mit der unterstützung dieser länder wird
es möglich sein das politische ziel der
isolierung russlands wirklich auch
voranzutreiben und das nächste ist eben
inwiefern schafft man es wirklich hier
maßnahmen zu treffen um die steigenden
lebensmittelpreise zu begrenzen denn
auch die sind natürlich ganz wichtig
dafür inwiefern andere staaten
insbesondere im globalen süden die
westliche position auch die
sanktionspolitik unterstützen oder
zumindest nicht aktiv zu deren umgebung
beitragen ja da würde ich gerne noch mal
einen haken das ist ja wirklich ein
interessantes thema also dieses
spannungsverhältnis zwischen dem
westlichen staaten und dem des globalen
südens die jetzt eben auch teilweise
eingeladen worden sind und die ja auch
vom krieg stark betroffen sind was wäre
wichtig für den westen wie könnte man es
schaffen eben diese staaten sozusagen
auf die eigene seite zu holen und sie
eben nicht so zu sagen ja in putins
einflusszone verbleiben zu lassen bzw
dass es sich dort hin entwickeln denn
das könnte ja auch passieren
also wenn wir uns diese staaten
anschauen verfolgen sie natürlich so
etwas wie eine schaukel politik oder
eine balance politik zwischen russland
und dem westen und hier ist es ganz
wichtig was kann die g7 diesen staaten
anbieten also beispielsweise
hinsichtlich finanzieller hilfen in
folge der korona pandemie auch die us
sanktionspolitik oder des krieges selber
und auch inwiefern ist die sieben in der
lage die steigenden lebensmittelpreise
zu begrenzen denn wenn es hier natürlich
substanzielle angebote gibt wenn es
einfach etwas gibt womit man diese
staaten locken kann ihnen die
unterstützung zusagen kann dann ist es
auch möglich dass sie sich zumindest
nicht wehren gegen die sanktionspolitik
eben keine aktive umgebung betreiben
dann letztlich wirklich ein ja ein
einschlagen in westliche
sanktionspolitik ist sicherlich
unwahrscheinlich aber das ziel ist
wirklich die schlupflöcher zu schließen
juli 65 schreibt uns über youtube wir
die demokratische welt müssen denen
autokraten die stirn bieten auch den
schwachen zeigen wie sie sich selbst
helfen können und nicht der dunklen
macht verfallen so drückt er es aus aber
das mit sicherheit eben auch ergänzend
sozusagen zu dem was sie gerade gesagt
haben also es geht neben dem krieg auch
um die ohnehin schon drängenden themen
unserer zeit klimawandel energiewende
die globale ernährungssituation und
andere mehr und da ist es vielleicht
auch noch mal ganz interessant noch mal
klar zu machen welche macht haben die g7
eigentlich das ist jetzt keine
organisation wie die nato oder die eu
was man die was können die g7 bewirken
konkret
also wenn man's die einzelstaaten
anschauen dann machen sie in der masse
ungefähr ein drittel der weltwirtschaft
aus und sie haben natürlich in ganz
wesentlichen internationalen
organisationen ein sehr starkes gewicht
ich würde sagen teilweise sogar ein
übergewicht also wenn wir an den
un-sicherheitsrat denken wenn wir an das
welternährungsprogramm denken auch den
internationalen währungsfonds
und hier kann natürlich oder können die
staaten der g 7 ihr gewicht nutzen um
eben maßnahmen zu erreichen die
beispielsweise den den ländern des
globalen südens helfen die folgen der
sanktionspolitik zu bekämpfen aber eben
auch ganz andere krisen wie
beispielsweise die klimakrise oder
regionale konflikte wie in afghanistan
es geht letztlich für den westen
eigentlich auch ein wenig darum die
angekratzte reputation im globalen süden
wieder herzustellen das ist natürlich
eine ganz harte währung wenn es einfach
darum geht international die isolierung
russlands die angestrebt ist durch diese
staaten weiter voranzutreiben weil es
die einschätzungen von sarah packung von
der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik an tag eins des g7
gipfels in ellmau ganz herzlichen dank
dass sie bei uns waren dankeschön sehr
gerne so und ich danke euch für euer
interesse wie gesagt einige fragen und
kommentare konnten wir mitnehmen wir
werden diesen gipfel natürlich weiter
verfolgen in den kommenden tagen dass
der stand bis hierhin einen schönen
restlichen sonntag wünschen wir euch und
einen guten start in die woche bis
demnächst